انا ممكن اسالك واقول لك انظمه في
المخالفات الماضيه تقول لي قطع اشاره 3
ريال لكن اجي اقول لك انظمه المرور في
الحوادث المروريه بقطع الاشاره يمكن ما
هتجاوب
مشعل يوسف الوابلي محقق حوادث
في المجال ثلاث سنوات حاليا ولا اخفيك في
اليوم اللي وقعت فيه العقد
لعمل المحقق حوادث كانت معي عقد ايضا من
احد البنوك بس فضلت اني ادخل محقق حوادث
انا في تحديات كبيره وبنفس الوقت ومن
اليوم وانا صغير شفت حالته وقفت احب شيء
سبحان
الذي بالتحديد
[موسيقى]
انت فاضي شغال فاضي لانه اول شيء انت
تشتغل مع ماسي الناس تشتغل بحقوق الناس
تشتغل باموال الناس وتحقق بحوادث مو بسيطه
ليش انك انت تحكم باليوم من عشر الى 15
حادث وتعطيني نسب باليوم الواحد
في سيارات على مليون ريال فلذلك لازم يكون
المحقق على الكفاءه عالي جدا
[موسيقى]
في بيت معروف
البيت مسيكين يقع في نصف في التقاطع زاويه
البيت
الباب الفله ما شاء الله من النوع البيوت
ببالها مفتوحه ودايم قاطن عندهم واحد
بحادث اي ما يصير حادث التقاطع الواحد
دائما يحاول تفاده فلما يتفاده ماله الا
باب البيت باب مفتوح بس يدخلوني يحكون في
الباب ويدخلون في نص الحوش بعدين يغطي في
هذيك المنطقه انا بنفس البيت لحالتين
وكل ما دقينا الجواز ودعوا قالوا ايه حادث
يا نازله عارفين الموضوع
[موسيقى]
اذكر باشرت حادث لبنتين البنات متحوشات
والكلام اللي صار بينهم اقشر شوي تعطيني
تحقيق في الحادث ابو عشر ثواني تتكلم عن
البنت ب50 ثانيه هديتهم انا جلستهم
بالسيارات واحده من البنات حضروا ابوها
الموقع الحادث ما مداني ابدا لابوها جايزه
[موسيقى]
بنت عمنا تواصل مع اول البنت الثانيه
هلا ابو فلان ايش الاخبار ايش العلوم بنتي
متصادمه مع بنتك كلهم سووا تنازل عن بعضهم
البنات
[موسيقى]
حق الحوادث هذه
نفسيتهم بخشومهم انا من يوم اطلع من
الدوام الى ما ارجع ضغط جدا ضغط جميع فئات
المجتمع اباشي
الكبير السن للسعودي لغير السعودي الاجنبي
ابي اشوف حوادث الناس نهدي من الناس يعني
كميه انت تسوي اكثر من شغله لحظه واحده
نفسيتك تتغير
18 دقيقه
[موسيقى]
تبديل السائق هذا واحد ليش لانه يصير
احيانا طرف ما معه رخصه ويروح يبدل
واحيانا
يجي مثلا شخص صدمه من الباب والصدام اللي
قدام عنده صدمه قديمه صدام اللي قدام مع
الباب فتحول يضيف صدمات قديمه
[موسيقى]
كان رمضان درجه الحراره 50 تصفق لها 50
فسالت السواق الخاص كيف صار حادث السياره
الاخرى دخلت عليه وسلم
من السالفه فيها احد يطق القزازه انا
سمعته بس
هنا واسمع والباب يفتح ويقفل يفتح ويقفل
في لحظه هذه اللي انا قاعد باشا
فجاه الباب ينفتح حق السياره اللي مظله
وينزل منها ولد يمكن عمره 14 15 سنه
نسيت نفسي ما همني لانه يرجع لاهل اليوم
يخطفوني ما عندي اي مشكله في اللحظه توجهت
بعيد شوي عنهم كاني صور الحادث وانا ما
كنت تصور كنت شابك السماعه قاعده اكلم
الجهات المختصه ابل انا رجعت سالته كيف
صار الحادث انا بنفسي نطيت ونفيت الدركسون
وسبت الحادث الولد
[موسيقى]
اذكر الشخص صادق اربع سيارات ومن سوق حظه
سيارتين من اربع سيارات هذه كانت من
السيارات الحليله يعني غاليه يعني انا
اتوقع بالحادث ذلك بتحمل من مجموعه اربع
سيارات من 300 الى 400 الف انا لما مقبل
عنده
[موسيقى]
الولد وجه الله
وبيت الشاشه حق الجوال
انا اذكر الحين توجه في عصر رقمي متغير
باستمرار المواكبه هي اساس النجاح ولاننا
رواد المستقبل الرقمي نوظف خبراتنا
وقدراتنا لنمكن نبتكر نبدع في تبني احدث
التقنيات وتوفير الحلول بكفاءه وذكاء
سلوجس باي اس تي سي
[موسيقى]
خلتني اعرف التعامل مع كل الناس اللي
في الضغوط عاليه يعني انت تروح الموقف حتى
لو كان الاشخاص طيبين وكويسين لكن في
اللحظه هيكونوا شديدين الفعل وتاكد ان
معاملتك مع الشايب كبير السن غير مع الشاب
مع البنت غير مع الولد داوم اشترى محقق
كنت راعي السرعه شوي الحين والله اني هادي
طيبه شايف من الكوارث
اضافتكم اهلا وسهلا حياكم